[Musica]
allora cosa c'era
[Applauso]
[Musica]
buon pomeriggio a tutti e volevo
innanzitutto ringraziare dell'invito
perchè comunque per me è un onore
parlare a questo the licks maggior
ragione del politecnico dove studio e le
immagini che avete visto sono quelle
delle ultime olimpiadi
come tutti gli atleti l'olimpiade è il
sogno
l'obiettivo di una carriera io mi
ricordo da quando ero piccola comunque
le seguivo mi piaceva sul divano e
sembravano tutti bravissimi una cosa
facilissima
anche se in realtà non è così perché lì
si vedono le immagini si vedono quel
minuto di gara quei secondi di gara ma
dietro c'è un enorme percorso un
percorso fatto di di fatiche di scelte
di fatiche perché comunque gli
allenamenti sono tanti sono anche due al
giorno tutti i giorni
se non tre ci vuole determinazione
perché non sempre si ha voglia di
allenarsi se ha voglia di di fare quello
che è in programma per cui scelte
sacrifici delle volte comunque bisogna
scegliere uno ti chiede poi venire
andiamo via week end magari è la gara
magari devi allenarti non puoi per cui
ti insegna anche a fare molte scelte io
faccio sport da quando ero piccola
perché la mamma non voleva tenerci e il
pomeriggio davanti alla televisione sul
divano per cui e io ho altri due
fratelli ci ha sempre portato in giro
fatto fare tante esperienze
poi ho fatto ginnastica artistica
trampolino elastico poi mi sono fatta
male nel 2010 durante un allenamento e
quello che penso è sempre che è stata
fortunata a farmi male durante un
allenamento comunque durante qualcosa
che mi piaceva piuttosto che in un
secondo momento dire mi sono fatta male
ma non posso più fare questa cosa è
tuttora a me piace a ginnastica la
guardo non rimpiango niente del mio
passato molti mi chiedono
ma dopo l'incidente ha avuto un momento
buio dove di vuoto di tristezza ma io
non l'ho mai percepito la mamma mi
racconta sempre dopo l'uscita da sala
operatoria era ancora un po sotto
l'effetto dell'anestesia e gli ho
chiesto se sarei tornata a camminare e
di non perderla anno a scuola perché mi
sono fatta male che era in seconda
superiore devo dire che va bene
fortunatamente la mamma insegnante
quindi sa come muoversi
però io sono riuscita a non perdere alla
scuola ho fatto sei mesi in ospedale e
andava a scuola con sky comunque sia la
scuola che c'è stato un lavoro che a cui
io devo dire grazie perché
ho continuato il mio percorso la mia
vita normale quindi questo grazie
soprattutto alla famiglia e tutti quelli
che mi sono stati intorno che non mi
hanno mai detto no ma troviamo il modo e
anche nuotare non è stato facile
iniziare perché si uno dice voglio
nuotare vado a cercare una società non è
così facile io ero in ospedale ho
conosciuto un ragazzo che aveva fatto le
paralimpiadi scorse mi ha fatto
conoscere l'allenatore da lì ho iniziato
però anche lui era spostato su reggio
emilia io sono di parma è a parma non
c'era una società quindi i miei genitori
hanno dovuto fare una società per
permettermi di nuotare e quindi la
strada non è spianata
poi ho deciso di studiare a milano sono
venuto a milano e anche qui
come faccio notare allora altri ragazzi
come me si sono spostati per studiare e
l'allenatore che fortunatamente abitava
a milano abbiamo fatto un gruppo e tutti
ci alleniamo studiamo comunque c'è da
conciliare gli allenamenti con gli orari
dell'università non è facile ogni tanto
bisogna rinunciare a uno o all'altro di
gare comunque per arrivare a
un'olimpiade sono tanti percorsi non
fatti soltanto di vittorie di successi
ma anche di sconfitte e penso che sia
anche questo che ti faccia andare avanti
ma proprio capire e prendere la
sconfitta come punto di partenza per
migliorare per andare sempre sempre più
avanti
il nuoto si è uno sport singolo ma è
fatto di tanti piccoli di tante cose
perché si in acqua se da solo ma c'è
l'allenatore se il preparatore c'è la
squadra e quindi a me piace pensare che
in effetti è così che si è tutti insieme
che si arriva all'obiettivo oltre al
nuoto comunque gli impegni fuori sono
tanti perché credo che sia importante
far conoscere quello che sto facendo io
che come fanno tanti altre ragazze la
normalità di questa cosa
anche sotto sotto forma del punto di
vista comunque di un'attenzione
mediatica dello sport paralimpico adesso
è un momento abbastanza pioneristico
dove bisogna sfruttare anche il momento
secondo me perché non si è molto
visibili ma si è fatta tanta strada e se
ne sta facendo quindi a me piace sempre
pensare si di fare le cose per me ma chi
viene dopo di me e per gli altri non
solo per me altrimenti sarebbe una cosa
fine a se stessa
quando fai conoscere queste cose a me
piace molto andare nelle scuole a
partire dai più piccoli perché sono
quelli che capiscono e poi ti fanno
anche domande strane per esempio c'è
stato un bambino che mi ha chiesto
perché io mi metto i pantaloni e le
mutande perché non sentendo e non
muovendo le gambe perché ti copri anche
gli rimane un po spiazzata marchetti
dicono però io ce l ho
oppure anche un'altra bambina che mi
portava sempre vicino al divano la
nostra amica mi fa sedere perché la
sedia per lei è un gioco e secondo me è
una cosa bellissima perché vuol dire che
è normale e mi ha detto adesso io mi
spingo con le braccia tu ai piedi hai le
gambe cammini tu e come darle torto
è impossibile allora gli ho detto va
bene però facciamolo la prossima volta
adesso l'ausilio e per cui è la
normalità di tutti i giorni oppure
un'altra ragazza che voleva far sport
non sapeva come come iniziare anche lei
di parma e aveva fatto una tesina di
terza media sulla mia storia su di me
un giorno mi ha incontrato mi ha voluto
incontrare e mi ha chiesto io voglio
fare il bike come faccio allora ho
provata dalle il contatto e la cosa
bella è stata un giorno che mi manda un
messaggio che vi voglio leggere e mi ha
detto sono andata in palestra per la
prima volta ma anche tu quando finisce
allenamento di senti libera e ti dà un
sacco di energie
io quando ricevo questi messaggi dico
che bello ho fatto qualcosa anche per
gli altri è questa qui è una cosa che
veramente mi riempie di gioia perché si
fai le cose per te stesso ma è secondo
me è importante bello saper condividere
e appunto per oltrepassare i limiti per
per fare qualcosa perché l'importante
penso che sia a porsi sempre un
obiettivo è la strada per arrivarci non
è spianata
1 ognuno se la deve creare e lungo
questa strada
puoi trovare tanti ostacoli ma bisogna
imparare a chiedere aiuto a saper farsi
aiutare
e infine condividere questo obiettivo
questo raggiungimento ma senza
scoraggiarsi e farlo appunto tutti
insieme quindi il saper chiedere il fare
il fare qualcosa con gli altri perché
tutti insieme si arriva a un obiettivo
ma anche saperlo condividere insieme
agli altri e quindi vi ringrazio
[Applauso]